hi und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
ein paar dieser Meldungen habt ihr
vielleicht in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen mitbekommen Waldbrände sogenannte
blitztere in Deutschland noch viel
größere Waldbrände in Kanada deren raus
sogar die Skyline von New York City
zeitweise eingetrübt hat und dann hören
wir von knapp 40 Grad in Teilen
vestibiriens und wenn wir über das Klima
diskutieren dann ist ja die Frage der
letzten Jahre eigentlich immer ob wir
dies 1,5 Grad Ziel des Pariser
Klimaabkommens noch einhalten können und
aktuell wird die Frage immer lauter die
hier schon hinter mir seht nämlich
reißen wir jetzt also viel viel früher
als angenommen schon die 1,5 Grad
globale Erwärmung wie extrem die Hitze
in diesem Jahr noch wird bei uns und
weltweit wie wir vielleicht jetzt noch
gegen steuern können und worauf wir uns
ähm Thema neue extreme vielleicht auch
einstellen müssen darüber wollen wir
heute sprechen und diskutieren und das
mache ich immer nicht alleine sondern
zum einen mit klimapphysiker herge
gösling vom Alfred wegner-institut und
mit ZDF Meteorologin Katja horneffer und
natürlich wie immer auch mit euch da
draußen wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema habt
zum Thema generell oder ganz gezielt an
unsere Experten und Expertinnen dann
schickt sie gerne direkt in den Youtube
Chat oder per Mail an die Mailadresse
die ihr unten eingeblendet seht bevor
wir jetzt aber anfangen zu diskutieren
und einzuordnen hat Ann-Kathrin Hecker
sich mal angeschaut wo ist eigentlich in
Deutschland gerade brennt
ein Truppenübungsplatz in Flammen diese
Woche bei Lübtheen in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern schon 2019 wütete
hier der bis dahin größte Waldbrand in
der Geschichte des Landes und es knallte
hier immer wieder in den letzten Tagen
denn das Feuer brachte alte Munition aus
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg zum explodieren
die tief im Boden vergraben liegt
mittlerweile ist das Feuer wieder unter
Kontrolle die Waldbrandgefahr in
Deutschland ist auch in diesem Sommer
wieder hoch im letzten Jahr verbrannte
hierzulande mehr Waldfläche als je zuvor
das berichten die Arbeitsgemeinschaft
Deutscher waldbesitzerverbände und der
deutsche Feuerwehr verbannt zwar meldet
der Deutsche Wetterdienst heute die
Waldbrandgefahr habe wieder leicht
abgenommen aber die Trockenheit bleibt
beim Waldbrand gefahrenindex leuchtet
vor allem der Nordosten des Landes
dunkelrot hier geht die höchste
Gefahrenstufe der Mai war nach Angaben
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes der
trockenste seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnungen weil kaum Regen
viel sind die obersten Schichten des
Bodens staubtrocken
Knochen trocken sind auch viele Wälder
im Süden etwa bei Pirmasens im Pfälzer
Wald auch hier brach gestern ein Feuer
aus die Fläche etwa so groß wie 20
Fußballfelder der Feuerwehr gelang es
gestern Abend den Waldbrand einzukesseln
ja und über diese Situation spreche ich
jetzt mit einer studiogastin nämlich mit
ZDF Meteorologin Katja horneffer hallo
schön dass du bei uns bist Katja sehr
gerne diese Bilder die wieder gerade
sehen die sind ja wirklich erschreckend
und es gibt aber jedes Jahr einige
Stimmen die sagen na ja Waldbrände die
gab es ja eigentlich irgendwie schon
jedes Jahr inwiefern sind die aber
dieses Jahr besonders naja bei uns in
Deutschland ist das schon ein relativ
neues Phänomen Waldbrände aus den
Urlaubsgebieten am Mittelmeer die sind
uns wohl bekannt ob nun Spanien Italien
Griechenland Frankreich da ist das
übliche gewesen aber hier bei uns in
Deutschland das ist so vorbei sind und
schon relativ früh im Jahr weil die geht
ist schon ungewöhnlich was muss denn
gegeben sein damit solche Waldbrände wie
sie gerade sehen überhaupt entstehen
können ja da gibt's ja Untersuchungen
dazu das ist in aller Regel der Mensch
der irgendwas schlechtes gemacht hat
weil kleiner Funkenflug vollkommen
ausreichend deswegen muss man halt so
sehr vorsichtig sein und möglichst den
Wald dann auch meiden manchmal werden ja
Waldgebiete dann auch wirklich gesperrt
für die Menschen dass man da eben halt
nicht mehr erhol versucht sondern
wirklich Abstand hält weil eben halt
schon eine Zigarettenkippe ein
vielleicht nicht ganz gelöschtes
Grillfeuer an sowas darf man überhaupt
nicht machen ja also es ist einfach sehr
sehr gefährlich und man weiß dass eben
wirklich der Mensch selbst eigentlich
die Hauptursache ist jedenfalls bei uns
hier in Deutschland jetzt haben wir ja
gerade an dieser Karte gesehen dass zum
Beispiel der Nordosten sehr gefährdet
ist also der war noch mal deutlich
dunkelroter eingefärbt wie kommen sowas
zustande naja der Nordosten hat ja ein
ganz anderen Boden das ist ein ganz
sandiger trockener Boden deswegen leiden
die sehr oft sehr schnell andere und wir
hatten ja jetzt durchaus auch wieder
regionale Unterschiede aber der
Nordosten ist eigentlich immer der wo
wir das erwarten können das ist jetzt
auch im Taunus oder dabei Pirmasens auch
mal Waldbrände gibt das ist eher die
ungewöhnliche die die Besonderheit in
diesem Jahr ein weiteres Phänomen was
wir gerade beobachten können oder von
dem wir gerade sprechen ist die
sogenannte Blitz Dürre kannst du uns
noch mal erklären was das eigentlich ist
ja also dürren entwickeln sich ja
normalerweise über Monate über Sarah und
bei der Blitz Dürre da ist es halt ein
bisschen anderes Phänomen es geht
nämlich viel viel schneller wir schauen
uns mal an wie das dieses Jahr war es
war ein sehr feuchtes Frühjahr da konnte
die Vegetation sich gut entfalten das
Wasser wurde also quasi aus dem Boden
rausgesaugt die Pflanzen haben das
Wasser verdunstet und dann kam sehr viel
Sonnenschein und sehr kräftiger Wind und
der hat dann den Boden immer mehr
ausgetrocknet erstmal konnte der Boden
noch gut Wasser nachliefern das sehen
wir hier ganz schön aber irgendwann war
es dann vorbei und dann innerhalb von
wirklich nur weniger Zeit weniger Wochen
oder so weiter haben wir dann diese
extreme Dürre und eine Blitz Dürre eben
deswegen weil es so wahnsinnig schnell
geht und auch nach einem sehr feuchten
früher sowas passieren kann sind diese
blitztüren ein neueres Phänomen wie wäre
der Begriff jetzt zwar gar nicht so
geläufig ja also im englischen heißt es
Flash Bros und davon die beobachtet man
schon seit ungefähr zehn Jahren
man stellt auch fest man sieht
Forschungen darüber wie sich die
blitzdiren im Vergleich zu den anderen
dörren verändert haben man stellt er
fest die blitzte stellt halt fest die
blitzdirn werden viel viel häufiger und
auch im Jahr 2018 gab es bei uns auch
schon mal so eine Blitz Dürre ob das
jetzt bei uns schon wirklich so zu
nennen ist das müssen Experten sagen ich
bin Meteorologin und jetzt da nicht die
Expertin nicht die Hydrologe die das
entscheiden kann ob das nun wirklich
eine blitztere ist aber blitzdirn werden
uns häufiger in gerade in den humiden
Regionen also in Europa auch in Teilen
von Asien häufiger erwischen
ich habe hier gerade schon mal so einen
Blick in die Kommentare geworfen und wir
haben auch direkt eine Frage an dich von
Sabine Specht auf Facebook die fragt wir
haben in der Eifel einen Vulkan der
brodelt wie verhält sich das Klima mit
dem Vulkan überhaupt kann es sein wenn
es heißer wird das aus dem Vulkan noch
mehr Aktivität kommen kann nee
Vulkanismus hat damit nichts zu tun aber
wohl keinismus sind insofern interessant
als wenn Vulkane ausbrechen dann werden
auch schwefelgase hoch in die Atmosphäre
transportiert und das könnte dann das
Klima kühlen wir sollten uns jetzt
trotzdem nicht
darauf nicht darauf hoffen dass wir
irgendwelche großen Vulkanausbrüche
haben natürlich aber Vulkane haben jetzt
so direkt mit dem Klimawandel oder mit
den mit den Waldbränden nichts zu tun
was ja aber schon was mit dem
Klimawandel und mit den hitzesommern der
letzten Jahre zu tun hat sind hitzetote
die es in Deutschland gibt und deswegen
hat jetzt Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach angekündigt einen sogenannten
hitzeschutzplan zu erarbeiten ich frage
mich jetzt wie notwendig ist sowas ist
total notwendig weil das Extremwetter
dass uns Menschen am meisten betrifft
ist die Hitze weder die Stürme noch die
Dürre noch Vince sondern es ist die
Hitze weil wir die Hitze einfach nicht
auf Dauer ertragen können und da die
Hitzewellen ja früher kommen länger
anhalten größere Gebiete betreffen und
weil es in den Hitzewellen noch immer
heißer wird also als Beispiel
großbritannien hatte im letzten Jahr 40
Grad das haben wir da noch nie gemessen
und das heißt auch bei uns werden diese
Spitzen der Hitzewellen immer höher
ansteigen und deswegen ist es ab
bisschen überfällig dass wir wirklich so
hitzeschutzpläne für ganz Deutschland
haben es gibt schon einige Regionen in
Deutschland die sowas haben einige
Städte Offenbach zum Beispiel ist mir
bekannt die das schon machen also es ist
total wichtig und ja absolut vordringen
hast du da ein Beispiel was in so einem
hitzeschutzplan dann drin stehen könnte
als möglicher natürlich also das ist
ganz klar es gibt es gibt so schattige
Räume es wird da dafür gesorgt dass die
vulnerabende Bevölkerung das meist
ältere Menschen kranke Menschen dass
sich um die gekümmert wird das zugesehen
wird dass die Medikament ist
Medikamentation stimmt dass sie genügend
trinken und so weiter und natürlich geht
es auch darum die Städte so umzubauen
dass sie den Klimawandel mehr
standhalten können es geht darum mehr zu
begründen Fassaden zu begründen Dächer
zu begründen es geht auch darum zu
entsiegeln damit eben eine bessere ein
besseres Klima da ist müssen uns
vorstellen Paris erwartet irgendwann
Temperaturen um 50 Grad in der Stadt ist
ein riesengroße total versiegelte Stadt
und deswegen machen die da einiges damit
das dann auch noch erträglich ist für
uns Menschen wie sieht das denn im
europäischen Vergleich aus du hast
angesprochen Paris oder auch UK 40 Grad
haben die schon vergleichbare Player
also in Frankreich gibt es schon
ziemlich lange dieses nationale calidit
oder wie das heißt also auf jeden Fall
sehr hitzeschutzplan die sind da halb
einfach schon weiter als wir um uns ist
echt überfällig dass wir uns da auch
drum kümmern wir haben hier nochmal eine
kurzfristige Frage aus der Community an
sie an dich und zwar frag Valentin auf
Youtube wie heiß wird es der nächste
Woche werden habe was von Horror Hitze
gehört von 40 Grad das hast du gerade
schon außer England
angesprochene Hitze erwarte ich jetzt
erstmal nicht aber die Wetterlage wird
sich komplett umstellen wir werden ab
Sonntag Montag Dienstag tatsächlich eher
so eine Südwestströmung haben davon ist
jedenfalls aktuell auszugehen das sagen
uns die Wettermodelle und dann wird es
schwul heißen das ist viel schwieriger
zu ertragen als sie trockene Wärme die
wir aktuell haben und dann können die
Temperaturen durchaus Richtung 33 34
oder 35 Grad steigen aber jetzt noch
nicht in Richtung 40 Grad also davor
brauchen wir uns jetzt erstmal nicht zu
fürchten das ist ja schon mal was Gutes
wir haben es gerade schon immer wieder
angesprochen es kommt gerade dazu
wirklich ungewöhnlichen Wetterlagen so
nennt man das ja lass uns mal auf diese
Europakarte gucken die Du mitgebracht
hast da sieht man vielleicht ganz gut
was aktuell außergewöhnlich ist ja ganz
genau man muss sich ja fragen wieso
kommt es eigentlich zu dieser blitztere
was steckt dahinter und dahinter steckt
eben diese ungewöhnliche Wetterlage in
kräftiges Hoch über Skandinavien und das
liegt eigentlich an einer Stelle wo wir
es da gar nicht erwarten jetzt ja
sondern wir warten das eigentlich am
Mittelmeer das weiß der ein oder die
andere wenn man Pfingsten oder so in
Urlaub fährt dann ist es am mittelme
eigentlich immer sonnig warm und schön
bei uns dagegen ziehen die Tiefs durch
das tun sie aber nicht man sieht obwohl
die ist entlang ziehen nämlich direkt
über das Mittelmeer und da gab es dann
diese kräftigen Unwetter auch und
deswegen man sieht das auch an der
Drehrichtung des Hochs ganz gut haben
wir eben diesen trockenen Ostwind der
kommt über die große Landfläche deswegen
ist er so trocken deswegen ist die Wärme
die wir aktuell haben so gut zu ertragen
ich habe jetzt extra mal den Sonntag
herausgesucht weil sich inzwischen schon
so ein bisschen wieder was geändert hat
da hatten wir halt bei uns dann
Temperaturen von bis zu 33 Grad und
damit war es zum Teil eben wirklich
wärmer als ermittel mehr und das ist
eine ungewöhnliche Wetterlage mit diesem
strahlenden Sonnenschein also so eine
Dürre muss gar nicht verbunden sein mit
großer Wärme sondern in dem Fall war es
eben der Sonnenschein und der Wind
das ist wirklich ungewöhnlich das ist ja
eigentlich genau andersrum als man es
erwarten würde wir haben hier noch eine
Frage und zwar frag Christoph K auf
Youtube ob es in Städten kühler werden
würde wenn dort weniger Verbrenner
rumfahren würden auf jeden Fall
das ist eine klare Antwort weil wir
natürlich alle irgendwie Treibhausgase
sparen müssen da ist CO2 zu den ist auch
Methan zu nennen und wenn wir nach
Möglichkeit keine Autos mehr fahren
würden wir können ja einfach mal so
träumen dann wäre das natürlich gut das
wäre natürlich auch für das Klima in der
Stadt besser weil natürlich dann auch
die Luft besser ist weil sie sie besser
atmen können und wenn wir dann noch
dafür sorgen dass die Städte gut begrüßt
sind dann würde uns das als Menschen
auch einfach gut tun und insofern sollte
man immer diesen direkten Aspekt mit
bedenken wenn man sich über
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen und Klimawandel
Gedanken gemacht das ist uns so fort
selbst zu Gute kommt
ja vielen vielen Dank dass du bei uns
warst ich hatte auch gerade jemand
geschrieben auf Facebook ich Ihre Frau
Horner vergangene zu ich habe dir auch
sehr gerne zugehört vielen Dank dass du
bei uns warst
ähm solche Extremwetter von denen wir
gerade gesprochen haben die machen sich
nicht nur in Deutschland bemerkt weil
die machen sich nicht nur in Europa
bemerkbar sondern auch global auch im
globalen Kontext gibt es quasi gerade
klimaanomalien die man auf Karten
deutlich sehen kann und die hat sich
Antoine kuscheln für uns angeguckt
seit Wochen wüten die Flammen in Kanada
hunderte Waldbrände gleichzeitig viele
sind außer Kontrolle
4,6 Millionen Hektar Land wurden bis
jetzt verwüstet und das Ende ist noch
lange nicht in Sicht 10.000 Menschen
müssen vor den Flammen fliehen es sind
die schwersten Waldbrände in der
Geschichte Kanadas und sie haben auch
Auswirkungen auf die USA der Rauch zieht
Richtung New York die Skyline eingehüllt
von giftigen smoke alles folgendes
Klimawandels sagen Experten
die Klimakrise ist eine der größten
Sicherheitsbedrohungen für den gesamten
Planeten und das ist eine Krise die
bereits heute jedes Jahr Milliarden
Dollar kostet und die geben wir nicht
dafür aus um die Krise zu verhindern
sondern nur um das Chaos zu beseitigen
diese Krise kostet Millionen
Menschenleben sie ist eine aktive
Bedrohung für den Frieden auf dem
gesamten Planeten
auch Europa muss sich auf Klima bedingte
Wetterkapriolen im Sommer vorbereiten
sagt die eu-umweltagentur der
klimawandelsorge dafür dass das Wetter
in Europa extremer werden der Ausblick
sei pessimistisch und das gilt auch für
das Wetterphänomen El Nino das laut
US-Experten letzte Woche begonnen hat
die anhaltende Erwärmung könnte dazu
führen dass El Niño 2024 zu einem
rekordwetterereignis wird die meisten
der wärmsten Jahre seit Beginn der
Aufzeichnungen die wir in der
Vergangenheit gesehen haben sind auf
Nino zurückzuführen
ein weiteres Problem die Erwärmung der
Weltmeere und da gibt es auch schlechte
Nachrichten denn die Oberfläche der
Weltmeere war im vergangenen Monat
wärmer als je zuvor in einem mai seit
Beginn der Aufzeichnungen
ja und über diese Anomalien und über zu
warme Meere sprechen wir jetzt mit
klimaphysiker Helge Gößling vom Alfred
Wegener Institut Halloween schön dass
Sie bei uns sind guten Tag Frau Reichelt
vielleicht gleich mal das besprechen was
wir da gerade im Beitrag gesehen haben
die Meeresoberfläche ist aktuell
ziemlich warm warum ist das so und
welche Folgen kann das haben ja erstmal
warum ist das so es gibt da mehrere
Gründe zwei Hauptaspekte spielen im
Moment eine Rolle das eine ist eben
dieses sich anbande El Nino Phänomen das
vor allem den Pazifik betrifft das heißt
da bekommen wir und sehen wir auch jetzt
bereits sehr warme Temperaturen entlang
des Äquators im Pazifik und vor der
Küste Südamerikas im Pazifik und das
zweite sind Anomalien die sich gerade in
den letzten Monaten auch im Nord
Atlantik aufgebaut haben und da ist
zuerst ein paar Monate ist sind die
Subtropen sehr warm geworden und
daraufhin auch der nördliche Bereich des
Nordlands das zusammen hat insgesamt die
Temperaturen hochgetrieben
ich habe hier mal eine Karte auf der wir
uns das vielleicht mal gemeinsam
angucken können wenn ihr euch jetzt
gerade fragt wo ist das eigentlich genau
und zwar liegt die hier auf meinem
Laptop da können wir das ganze
exemplarisch noch mal anschauen also
hier haben wir den Normalzustand Herr
Gössling sie sagten gerade um den
Äquator ist die Meeresoberfläche ja eh
wärmer oder richtig genau und dann kann
ich hier mal durch einen Klick
simulieren wie diese Anomalien von dem
wir gerade sprechen aussehen wo müssen
wir da jetzt noch mal genau gucken genau
was ich gerade beschrieben habe ist
einmal auf der linken Seite da sehen wir
diesen Streifen entlang des Äquators der
geht da von links nach rechts hier
braune Streifen da das ist schon äh der
heran nahende elinio und vor allem ist
es im Moment auch an der Küste
Südamerikas im Pazifik da sehen sie
dieses braune bis rote das ist dieser El
Nino der eben jetzt schon ordentlich
Fahrt aufnimmt und dann ein andererseits
sehen wir da im Nordatlantik
Anomalien die wirklich außergewöhnlich
sind einmal in den Subtropen das ist
also da jenseits der Küste Afrikas und
da also dieser Anomalien haben sich
schon im Frühjahr entwickelt und oben
sehen wir also südlich von Grönland und
Island sehen wir dann eben zusätzlich
auch braun rote Farben das sind die
Anomalien die sich vor allem in den
letzten vier Wochen sowas
aufgetürmt haben
wie extrem sind in dieser anomaliene
Anomalie das ist ja schon ein starkes
Wort also anders als normal abweichend
von der Norm können Sie uns noch mal
einordnen wie extrem das gerade ist ja
also dieser El Niño der ist ich würde
sagen ein normaler aber kräftiger El
Nino dieses Phänomen gibt es ja so
man sagt typischerweise alle zwei bis
sieben Jahre also da ist eine gewisse
Unregelmäßigkeit auch mit verbunden aber
wenn so ein kräftiger elenio passiert
das war z.B auch
1997/98 so wir hatten 2015/2016
ellino dann ist das auch geht das mit
ähnlichen Anomalien ein her dass im
Nordatlantik ist noch deutlich
außergewöhnlicher also wenn man sich da
anschaut über den Nordatlantik gemeldet
da sind die Temperaturen im Moment ein
halbes Grad wärmer über diesen großen
Bereich gemeldet als je zuvor zu dieser
Jahreszeit in den letzten paar
Jahrzehnten und das ist schon eine
wirklich sehr kräftige Anomalie
ja wenn ihr euch da draußen gerade fragt
ein Ninjo habe ich schon mal gehört habe
aber kein klares Bild davon diese
Phänomen haben so viele Diesler und
Petra Riffel noch mal für uns erklärt
etwa alle zwei bis sieben Jahre kommen
die meeres- und Luftströmungen im
tropischen Pazifikraum Durcheinander mit
teils verheerenden Folgen das sogenannte
El Nino Phänomen
normalerweise drücken starke Passatwinde
das warme Wasser an der Oberfläche des
Pazifiks nach Westen hier verdunstet es
und sorgt für das feuchtwarme Klima in
den Gebieten um Australien Indonesien
und Südostasien vor der Küste
Südamerikas strömt kaltes
nährstoffreiches Wasser nach oben und
ersetzt das warme Oberflächenwasser das
Klima hier eher kühl und trocken
während El Nino werden die Passatwinde
wieder schwächer oder wechseln sogar die
Richtung dadurch endet der Abtransport
des warmen Oberflächenwassers nach
Westen stattdessen verdunstet das Wasser
vor der pazifiküste von Süd und
Lateinamerika starke Regenfälle und
Stürme drohen
oft kann der ausgetrocknete Boden die
großen Wassermassen nicht schnell genug
aufnehmen es kommt zu Überschwemmungen
und Erdrutschen
an der asiatischen und australischen
Pazifikküste wird es dagegen extrem
trocken die Folgen Dürre Ernteausfälle
und Waldbrände ein El Nino Ereignis kann
das Wetter weltweit beeinflussen heftige
Stürme in Mexiko und in den USA sind
möglich ebenso wie dürren in Südafrika
die Auswirkungen auf Europa und vor
allem Deutschland sind allerdings nur
sehr gering über die auslöser dieses
klimaphänomens können die Forscherinnen
und Forscher bis heute nur spekulieren
ja wir haben also El Nino wir haben wie
sie sagen diese weitaus ungewöhnlicheren
Anomalien im Nordatlantik und dann gibt
es ja aktuell viele weitere Brennpunkte
aber einer ist eben auch die Antarktis
die zunehmend eisfrei bleibt was
passiert da gerade
ja das ist auch sehr interessant dass es
etwas was wir in den letzten Jahren sehr
intensiv betrachten wir haben im Grunde
bis ungefähr
2015/2016 waren wir eher erstaunt dass
in der Antarktis vor allem mit dem
antarktischen mehr als noch nicht so
viel passiert ist bzw sah sogar fast so
aus als würde das antarktische mehr als
leicht zunehmen und wir haben das immer
als das antarktische Meer als paradox
bezeichnet denn was die Klimamodelle uns
schon gesagt haben war auch in der
Antarktis sollte die Schmelze allmählich
losgehen und ungefähr
2016/2017 ist plötzlich tatsächlich die
Ausdehnung des mehr als es auch auf ein
deutlich niedriges Niveau runtergesagt
und in den letzten Jahren ist es
tatsächlich auf diesem sehr niedrigen
Niveau geblieben das heißt auch da hat
sich gezeigt okay das war doch nicht so
falsch was wir erwartet haben was auch
die Klima Modelle uns gesagt haben und
es sieht wohl so aus als würde da der
Klimawandel jetzt endgültig auch um die
Antarktis herum angekommen sein
ja das klingt auf jeden Fall nicht gut
ich habe auch gelesen dass in der
Antarktis die Fläche von quasi 6 mal
Deutschland aktuell fehlt ich gucke
gerade mal so ein bisschen in die
Kommentare was die Leute auf jeden Fall
umtreibt sind die Brände das ist ja eine
Folge des Klimawandels die wir
hierzulande auch ganz deutlich spüren
und hier fragt jemand auf YouTube in
Kanada ist letztes Jahr im Sommer mitten
im Land eine ganze Kleinstadt an einem
kleinen Fluss aus dem Nichts abgebrannt
droht und sowas auch hier
das ist sehr schwer zu sagen also das
sind dieser Ort Lippen in Kanada da sind
tatsächlich Temperaturen von fast 50
Grad entstanden das waren das hat die
vorherigen Rekorde in dieser Region um
sage und schreibe fünf Grad in die Höhe
getrieben
es ist sehr schwierig zu sagen ob sowas
hier bei uns auch passieren kann dass
man plötzlich also bisher sind ja die
Rekorde bei uns bei sowas wie 41 Grad ob
jetzt plötzlich aus so einer sehr
ungewöhnlichen meteorologischen Lage auf
einmal 46 Grad werden können das kann
man wohl nicht ausschließen aber ist
auch sehr sehr schwierig einzuordnen
wir haben ja auch ähm kritische Stimmen
äh hier fragt z.B jemand auf Facebook
früher nannte man das Sommer heute wird
ein Drama drauf gemacht das ist
eigentlich keine Frage sondern Kommentar
wie reagieren sie auf solche Kommentare
naja wenn man sich die Daten anschaut
dann ist es ja im Grunde sehr klar also
diese es ist auch so wenn wir die
Hitzewellen uns anschauen und sogenannte
attributionsstudien machen also
zuordnungsstudien das wurde in den
letzten ungefähr zehn Jahren sehr gut
entwickelt diese Technik dann können wir
mittlerweile ziemlich gut sagen um
welchen Faktor sich die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für solche
Hitzewellen und auch deren Intensität
verändert hat und gerade für solche
Hitzewellen da findet man oft dass um
dass die um so etwas wie den Faktor 30
wahrscheinlicher geworden sind also eine
Hitzewelle die damals ohne den
Klimawandel vielleicht alle 100 Jahre
stattgefunden hat die könnte dann
mittlerweile alle drei Jahre stattfinden
also insofern ist da nicht von reinem
Zufall und das war schon immer so kann
da wirklich nicht die Rede sein
wenn wir über diese Fragen sprechen dann
sprechen wir ja nicht nur
wissenschaftlich über die
anhand den Daten die Menschen und
Wissenschaftler wie sie erheben sondern
diese Diskussion wird gerade vermehrt
auch im letzten Jahrzehnt ja politisch
geführt das stellt sich die Frage was
müssen wir als Menschheit eigentlich tun
um diesen Planeten zu bewahren und jetzt
hat er die Fridays for future Aktivistin
Greta tunberg Anfang der Woche auf der
prekord in Bonn das ist eine Art
vorbereitendes Event für die große
Klimakonferenz folgendes gesagt
die kommenden Monate und die kommenden
Jahre die gerade jetzt entscheidend
dafür sein werden wie die Zukunft
aussehen wird was wir jetzt entscheiden
wird den Rest der Zukunft der Menschheit
bestimmen
und ob wir uns dafür entscheiden oder
nicht wenn wir es nicht tun wird es ein
Todesurteil für unzählige Menschen sein
und ist bereits ein Todesurteil für
unzählige Menschen die heute an
vorderster Front der Klimakrise leben
ja und immer im Zentrum dieser
politischen Diskussion und der Maßnahmen
bzw der fehlenden Maßnahmen steht ja
dieses 1,5 Grad Ziel was im Pariser
Klimaabkommen festgeschrieben wurde
jetzt waren einige ExpertInnen davor
dass wir dieses 1,5 Grad Ziel zeitweise
schon dieses oder nächstes Jahr reißen
könnten das klingt ja sehr dramatisch
wie schätzen Sie das ein also erstmal zu
diesem 1,5 Grad Ziel wenn man sich
einzelne Tage anguckt dann ist es
tatsächlich so dass wir im Moment schon
daran kratzen und ich glaube auch gerade
die letzten Tage nach der vorläufigen
Analysen da war man schon mal einzelne
Tage tatsächlich bei dieser 1,5 Grad
Marke gemeint aber auch im Pariser
Abkommen ist dass man über diese Marke
über mehrere Jahre hinausgeht das heißt
über dieses Politikum 1,5 Grad da sind
wir noch nicht das ist etwas was er in
sowas wie grob 15 Jahren zu erwarten ist
wenn es so weitergeht wie zu erwarten
ist wenn
man sich ein einzelnes Jahr anguckt dann
da gibt es tatsächlich aktuelle
Vorhersagen von der weltmetropologie
Organisation und die hat das beziffert
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass eines
der nächsten fünf Jahre die 1,5 Grad
reist dass die bei ungefähr 20% liegt
das wäre dann das ganze Jahr mittelt
mehr als 1,5 Grad über dem
vorindustriellen Niveau
jetzt ist es ja eigentlich ein politisch
vor allem auch international
festgeschriebenes ziel dieses 1,5 Grad
Ziel einzuhalten was müsste denn
politisch ihrer Meinung nach passieren
also welche Maßnahmen müssten jetzt
ergriffen werden um das noch einhalten
zu können
naja über einzelne politische Maßnahmen
da kann und will ich mich nicht wirklich
äußern aber was klar ist und was schon
lange klar war ist dass die
Treibhausgasemissionen insbesondere das
Verbrennen der fossilen Brennstoffe wenn
man denn nicht da deutlich darüber
hinausschießen will dann müssen die sehr
schnell sehr stark sinken
jetzt ist es aber auch so dass wir alle
vor allem im Sommer schon merken es wird
wärmer also wir merken den Klimawandel
ja heute schon und müssen uns
dementsprechend auch anpassen was sind
denn so Anpassungsstrategien die wir
Ihrer Meinung nach in Deutschland in den
nächsten Jahren ergreifen müssen
naja für Deutschland auch wenn das nicht
meine Kern Expertise ist eine Sache die
ziemlich klar auf der Hand liegt ist das
unser Umgang mit der Ressource Wasser
auch hier in Deutschland
dass das wir da Änderungen vor uns haben
die wir einen eingehen müssen
das andere was auch relativ klar ist
dass natürlich Deiche Deichanlagen
Küstenschutz dass der vorangebracht
werden muss ich will an dieser Stelle
aber auch darauf hinweisen wir müssen
gar nicht so weit schauen in Südamerika
sind ja auch gerade diese diese
Ressource Wasser das Problem ist noch
mal deutlich größer das ist wirklich ein
Hotspot des Klimawandels und da das
haben wir jetzt in den letzten Monaten
und Jahren auch vor allem in Spanien in
Frankreich gesehen also da es ist auch
klar es kann nicht nur um Reduktion von
Emotionen gehen wir müssen auch
Anpassungsmaßnahmen voranbringen
ich gucke gerade noch mal in die
Kommentare es gibt auf jeden Fall noch
ein paar Fragen die ich Ihnen gerne
stellen würde bzw die Ihnen unsere
Zuschauer anzuschauen gerne stellen
würden hier fragt jemand auf Youtube was
ist denn eigentlich mit dem Ozonloch von
dem früher so viel gesprochen wurde
heute kein Thema mehr
ja das Ozonloch in der Südhemisphäre das
hat sich eben dadurch dass man diese
FCKW verboten hat ist das auf dem Weg
der Heilung sozusagen das Ozonloch hat
aber mit dem Klimawandel nur am Rande zu
tun also so gut wie gar nicht ozon ist
selber zwar auch ein Treibhausgas aber
eigentlich hat es damit nicht so viel zu
tun also da
sehen wir eine Linderung es gibt noch
andere Faktoren ich will aber nicht zu
weit ins Detail gehen
Ozonloch ist mit dem Klimawandel also
kein maßgeblicher Faktor
und hier fragt jemand Thema
Lösungsansätze auf youtube ist
geo-ingenieuring eine Chance ja Gio
Engineering ich glaube es ist wichtig
Forschung zu betreiben und sich
anzuschauen was kann man machen ich bin
aber skeptisch ich habe selber auch
Studien gemacht zum Beispiel haben uns
angeschaut eine Technik mit der man
versuchen könnte theoretisch das
arktische Meer Eis
zu erhalten da waren aber in dieser
Studie die Auswirkungen auf andere
Bereiche außerhalb der Arktis waren sehr
sehr klein und insgesamt auch wenn man
sich andere Maßnahmen ansieht ist sind
die Möglichkeiten die wir mit Gio
Engineering möglicherweise hätten
höchstwahrscheinlich sehr gering die
würden andere Probleme mit sich bringen
da können wir also absolut nicht drauf
wetten aber ich bin dafür dass das
trotzdem auch weiter bevorzugt werden
sollte und vielleicht können Sie für
alle zuschauen ZuschauerInnen in diesem
Begriff noch nicht gehört haben und sich
gerade fragen was ist das noch mal kurz
erklären was dir Engineering eigentlich
ist
Engineering heißt dass man versucht im
großen Stil in das Klimasystem als
Mensch einzugreifen ich habe gerade
schon eine Technik erwähnt die ist
allerdings die wird eher ganz am Rande
diskutiert eine andere die eigentlich
mehr diskutiert wird vorhin hat die
Kollegin gesprochen über die kühlende
Wirkung von Vulkan über diese Aerosole
die in die Atmosphäre gebracht werden
und tatsächlich ist eine Überlegung dass
man so ähnliche Partikel mit Flugzeugen
in der unteren Stratosphäre also
ungefähr da wo die Flugzeuge
normalerweise auch tatsächlich fliegen
einbringt und das könnte eine gewisse
kühlende Wirkung bringen diese kühlende
Wirkung die hätte aber ein ganz anderes
räumliches Muster als der Klima also als
die CO2 induzierte Erwärmung das heißt
man würde ein ganz anderes Klima Muster
am Ende erhalten man müsste das außerdem
ständig weitermachen wenn man plötzlich
aufhören würde mit solcher Maßnahme dann
würde die Erwärmung dann ganz plötzlich
ganz stark kommen man würde auch nicht
die Uhrzeit sehr anversorgung damit
irgendwie in irgendeiner Form einnehmen
also bisher ist da wirklich nicht viel
Hoffnung dass uns das in irgendeiner
Weise groß weiterbringen kann
gibt es noch eine sehr konkrete Frage
die sich auch um das 1,5 Grad Ziel dreht
und zwar fragt Ahmed auf Youtube kann
man Voraussagen um wie viel Meter der
globale Meeresspiegel bei 1,5 Grad
Erderwärmung steigen würde
das ist eine sehr schwierige Frage und
zwar muss man da erstmal fragen bis wann
überhaupt es ist so dass nämlich dieser
Meeresspiegelanstieg sich sehr langsam
nur abspielt das heißt wenn wir jetzt
die Temperaturen so einfangen bzw die
Emission so einfangen und runterfahren
so dass wir die globalen Temperaturen
dann bei 1,5 Grad
übervorindustriellen Niveau halten dann
wird sehr lange nichtsdestotrotz der
Meeresspiegel weiter steigen
ob der aber immer was heißt immer über
viele Jahrhunderte weiter steigt und
irgendwann ein zwei drei vier fünf Meter
erreichen könnte in vielen Jahrhunderten
dafür haben wir noch nicht gut genug
verstanden wie stabil oder instabil das
grönländische Eisschild die Weste
Antarktis also diese großen Eismassen
wie genau die auf welches Temperaturen
Niveau reagieren das ist insofern schwer
zu sagen
richtig ich glaube an der Stelle ist die
Frage vielleicht schon einigermaßen
beantwortet ja ihr seht da sind auf
jeden Fall alles sehr sehr komplexe
Zusammenhänge mit dem man sich zum Thema
Klima befassen muss wir haben hier quasi
noch mal so eine Art grundlagenfrage zum
ganzen Thema Klimawandel ich sehe da
sind einige Begriffe auf jeden Fall noch
unklar und wir können ja gerne mal
klären hier fragen zwei Menschen nach
den kipppunkten bzw auf Englisch Tipping
Points was ist das eigentlich und welche
Bedeutung haben die gerade in der
aktuellen Diskussion
ja diese diese Kipppunkte oder Kipp
Elemente das sind Teile des Klimasystems
bei denen man überlegt ob es sein könnte
dass wenn man die weit genug aus dem
Normalbereich bringt dass die dann mehr
oder weniger von selber kippen sowie
einen Stuhl den man bis zu einem
gewissen Punkt
bewegt und wenn man dann weiter bewegt
dann kippt er von selber um so jetzt ist
die große Frage ob wir solche
kippelemente tatsächlich im Klimasystem
haben oder nicht es gibt auch andere
eine etwas weitere Definition ist das
irgendetwas sich plötzlich relativ
schnell ändert aber vielleicht nicht von
selber kippt das heißt das ist alles so
ein bisschen Graubereich
es kann tatsächlich auch echte
kippelemente geben zum Beispiel wird das
sehr diskutiert bei dem grünländischen
Eisschild und bei der Westen Antarktis
aber das Beispiel Grönland wollen wir
vielleicht hier einmal machen wenn
nämlich tatsächlich der Grünen frische
Eisschild von oben abschmilzt weil es
warm wird dann Gerät ja die Oberfläche
Grünlands in tiefere Luftschichten und
und sie wissen wahrscheinlich vom
Bergsteigen je höher man geht desto
kühler wird es das heißt wir sagen jetzt
in tiefere Atmosphärenschichten die
wärmer sind und dann könnte es sein dass
man irgendwann so tief abgeschmolzen ist
dass das dann so warm ist und das gesamt
der gesamte Eisschild wegschmilzt und
das würde zum Beispiel in Grönland dann
auch mit fünf bis sieben Meter
Meeresspiegelanstieg einhergehen und so
weiter würde aber
viele Jahrhunderte dauern insofern ist
das nichts was uns jetzt für die
nächsten Jahrzehnte die allergrößte
Sorge machen muss wo genau aber so ein
Punkt liegen könnte wo wirklich das
grönländische Eisschild komplett
abschmilzt da sind dicke Fragezeichen
dran so ähnlich für die Weste Antarktis
was man aber auch sagen muss ist das so
ein Kipppunkt fürs gesamte Klimasystem
wo also jetzt die Erwärmung plötzlich
zum Beispiel im
Zusammenhang mit dem Permafrost wird das
manchmal diskutiert ob da so viel
Kohlenstoff so viel CO2 oder auch Methan
freigesetzt wird das auf einmal die
Erwärmung die meinetwegen vom Menschen
bis auf zwei Grad geschoben wird und
jetzt auf einmal sich verselbstständigt
und auf sowas wie fünf Grad hoch geht
das halten wir für sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich also da sind zwar
verstärkende Effekte die die Erwärmung
verstärken können zum Beispiel um sowas
wie 20 Prozent zusätzliche Erwärmung
aber dass die Erwärmung insgesamt sich
verselbstständigen würde das ist sehr
sehr unwahrscheinlich
sehr gut dass wir das mal so anschaulich
erklärt haben eine Folge des
Klimawandels oder ein Symptom was viele
sich ja auch kennen sind Wälder Kranke
Wälder tote Wälder und die fragt noch
jemand wie viele Jahre wird es dauern
bis ein toter Wald wie am Harz wieder
gesund ist
das kann ich sehr schwer sagen da liegt
nicht so wirklich meine Expertise was
ich aber weiß über viele dieser Gebiete
ist ja dass da die das da die Menschen
die diese Wälder da betreiben und
pflegen die Förstereien und so weiter
dass die gar nicht da wieder
Fichtenmonokulturen pflanzen wollen
sondern die wollen die Wälder da sowieso
umbauen und zum Teil ist es wohl auch so
dass sie das jetzt so ein bisschen da
aus der Not eine Tugend machen und da
haben sie so viele tote Bäume und dann
wird kann man da dann jetzt schnell auch
mehr mischt und
andere Bäume eben mit unterbringen aber
das natürlich sind das lange Zeiten bis
man da irgendwie einen stabileres
waldsystem etablieren kann
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie meine Fragen
und die Fragen von unseren Zuschauern
und Zuschauerinnen so ausgiebig
beantwortet haben danke schön danke
schön
ja ich sehe auf jeden Fall wenn ich hier
im Blick in den Chat werfe dass das
Thema Klima Klimawandel und auch
Einfluss auf unser Leben sehr
beschäftigt hier fragt zum Beispiel
jemand warum wurde in den letzten 30
Jahren nichts getan was heute geschieht
war doch damals schon bekannt und hier
auch eine eher pessimistische Stimme auf
die Frage die uns heute beschäftigt hat
natürlich reißen wir die 1,5 Grad
zumindest mittelfristig Frankreich
bereitet sich auf vier Grad vor und auch
in meiner Heimatstadt Düsseldorf plus 4
Grad vorbereitet werden
wie das sich weiterentwickeln wird wir
bleiben hier bei ZDF heute live für euch
dran zu den verschiedenen Nachrichten
Themen natürlich auch die die mit dem
Klima zu tun haben und hier habe ich zum
Schluss noch einen sehr netten Kommentar
bekommen schreibt Karl Henderson auf
Facebook gute informative Sendung da
lernt man was das freut mich auch ich
lerne hier jeden Tag dazu und freue mich
wenn Ihr nächstes Mal wieder einschaltet
bei ZDF heute live bis dann